um as far as like the violent stuff yeah
he would um the guns would start out
small and then they would turn out like
really big the burner like he would have
the burner to my temple waking me up
whether I'd be sleeping on this side or
I'd be sleeping on this side it was
always
I don't know the man was violent the man
blamed a lot of stuff on the war that he
was in so
how far did you go to school
how far am I in school well I've done
three months uh this was back when I was
18 I did three months of cosmetics and
unfortunately the relationship I was in
for five years
I wasn't allowed to go to school I
wasn't allowed to work I wasn't allowed
to even have an apartment of my own
without that man messing with me